all right i was not initially going to
talk about this story which is why i'm
sort of a day late on it although much
of what i'm going to talk about actually
happened in the last 12 to 16 hours uh
there is a um i think it's appropriate
to say a pop singer
named nicki minaj
who has been posting some sort of
strange things to twitter lately and
other social media related to the
pandemic and related to science
nicki minaj has close to 200 million
that's not that's not an error close to
200 million followers across all social
media platforms
and the day before yesterday she tweeted
a very strange anecdote
about the coronavirus vaccine where
nicki minaj said quote
my cousin in trinidad
won't get the vaccine
cause his friend got it and became
impotent
his testicles became swollen
his friend was weeks away from getting
married
now the girl called off the wedding
so just prey on it and make sure you're
comfortable with your decision not
bullied presumably meaning not bullied
into getting the vaccine now this is a
really weird anecdote for a few
different reasons first of all there's
nothing in the scientific literature
that suggests testicular swelling can be
a cause can be caused by the vaccine
it's also sort of strange because
why would swollen testicles mean the
wetting is off
is it because you're getting medical
treatment or like the does the the
fiance just not want to be married to a
guy whose testicles swelled
or is it that actually the swollen
testicles were the result of maybe an
std
obtained from
infidelity i don't know that that was
sort of my tongue-in-cheek suggestion i
got involved in this and responded
actually and said quote
this is a very technical response i said
is it maybe possible the swollen apple
bags
were an std from cheating
and that's why the wedding was called
off now some of the amateur
doctors in my audience told me david
there are no stds that cause testicular
swelling that's not true
i researched it in fact both chlamydia
and gonorrhea can cause something called
orchitis which is a swelling of the
testicles so anyway
like we don't we don't do anecdotal
stuff we go by we go by science and uh
peer review and randomized controlled
trials and you know one person whose
testicles swell in trinidad doesn't
really tell us too much about what we
need to know this story has exploded so
first of all
yesterday on cnn
jake tapper actually asks dr fauci about
this specifically take a listen to this
speaking of uh trusted messengers
and pop star nicki minaj tweeted
yesterday that she's not vaccinated
she's doing her own research and then
she shared an anecdote i found rather
unbelievable to be honest about alleged
side effects that her cousin's friend
supposedly experienced in trinidad i
wouldn't normally even ask you about
this but but nicki minaj has nearly 180
million followers on twitter and in your
instagram combined she's beloved by her
fans she's a huge talent obviously her
tweet was seized upon by vaccine
opponents as some sort of evidence i
want you to address what she said
because for anyone out there who has any
questions about this
dr fauci is there any evidence that the
pfizer the mederna or the j j vaccines
cause any reproductive issues in men or
women
the answer to that uh jake is a
resounding no
there's no evidence that it happens nor
is there any mechanistic reason to
imagine that it would happen
so the answer to your question is no
how can health authorities even attempt
to combat this kind of misinformation
coming from somebody who is a huge and
beloved international star like nicki
minaj
it's very difficult
the there is a lot of misinformation
mostly on social media and the only way
we know to counter miss and
disinformation
is to provide a lot of correct
information all right so that might have
been it right nicki minaj tweets about
the swollen testicles the wedding is off
it makes one day of rounds and it's sort
of like there's no evidence for this
there's no medical reason this is this
is one person
uh just because something happened
after something else doesn't mean that
it was caused by that thing
uh okay fine but then tucker carlson
jumps in
and tucker carlson is very interested in
this story very very interested in this
story and the clips from tucker carlson
are indistinguishable from parody first
tucker offering a clarification
um it is not nicki minaj's cousin's
testicles that were swollen it is nicki
minaj's cousin's friend's testicles
things about that tweet last night we
read it we put the graphic on the screen
and we suggested that nicki minaj's
cousin is the one with the swollen
testicles in trinidad right and we were
wrong and we want to admit it we
henceforth correct the record
nicki minaj's cousin's testicles are not
swollen as far as we know he's fine it's
nicki minaj's cousin's friend's
testicles who are swollen yeah okay so
that's already crazy but then this is
really the wacky part
tucker wants to interview nicki minaj's
cousin's friend
about his swollen testicles
orchidis now is going to be a subject
on the tucker carlson program and not
only does tucker want to interview the
guy
tucker tucker's willing to fly to
trinidad
[Laughter]
this is a clip
this may be
the clip of tucker carlson that would be
you know in an archive to be to be
reviewed a thousand years from now by
society
listen to this we haven't been able to
figure out whether this show is
broadcast in trinidad
but if nicki minaj's cousin's friend is
watching or his former fiance who's
watching we want to hear your story
we'll come to port of spain to see you
let us know
one case of swollen testicles in
trinidad
and tucker will take his entire
production team down there and do an
entire show about your swollen testicles
guys
we're in real trouble here aren't we i
mean that this now is going be i don't
even know
how to characterize
and quantify and qualify
the insanity that is spreading like a
virus in this country
um one thing after another after another
it is truly truly stunning but tucker
he's on the story he's ready to go
interview
nicki minaj's
uh cousin's friend
about
his allegedly swollen testicles which
came
chronologically
after supposedly receiving
some vaccine but we don't really know
much else about it
we're screwed guys right i mean this is
this is not
humanity is not pointing in the right
direction at this point in time i think
we can say
one of our sponsors is blue blocks blue
light glasses i've sometimes had issues
falling asleep at night eventually
realize some of it might be coming from
the blue light emitted by my phone and
computer screens peer-reviewed studies
show blue light can suppress the hormone
melatonin which can make it hard to fall
asleep because your sleep rhythms are
disturbed i've seen a lot of improvement
since i started using blue light glasses
from blue blocks most companies make
blue light glasses in a mass-produced
way with no quality standards but blue
blocks glasses are made in actual optics
labs in their australian headquarters
they have over 40 modern frames you can
choose from they have a prescription
version non-prescription even reading
glasses and for every pair of glasses
blue block cells they give a pair of
reading glasses to someone in need
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to blue blocks dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath the video
and there's also free shipping worldwide
on orders over 115 dollars